[Music]
thank you
when Ireland had locked down Patrick
Dexter tuned up and ventured onto social
media I was a school teacher so I played
in my classroom of primary school
children and now playing to millions of
people online
his recitals from the West Coast turned
him into a global sensation what was it
they connected with the music the
landscape you're a beautiful dog or just
the freedom of this place during
lockdown as well yeah there's a certain
um like visceral impact that the west of
Ireland hasn't even you can feel it now
and this wild weather we're having it
and I think that mixed with the sound of
the cello and instrumental music in
general just the way that it touches
your soul and reaches into you and asks
for you to add something to it it
doesn't tell you what to think with
words it sort of suggests a Feeling
[Music]
foreign
Ed in County Mayo the ancestral homeland
of Joe Biden he has performed for the
U.S president and been viewed by
millions worldwide
you say that you underestimated the
extent to which social media could be a
force for good so you must have some
concerns about its direction of travel
now there is such negativity there but
let's just be aware that if this if we
lose this on Twitter in particular
because I think it has a special role to
play in that space there's something
really tragic being lost and to see it
go down the tubes as things might be
going is is I think a great loss um but
no matter what happens if the ship of
Twitter sinks at the bottom of the
Atlantic there I'll still be playing my
channel
most of Patrick's fans from around the
world engage with him on social media
but the postman did deliver one letter
here from Canada simply addressed to the
cellist who plays outside his Cottage in
mayo
his debut album entitled solos was the
best selling of its genre
music in this magical location having
introduced a whole new audience to the
cello David Blevins Sky News at Newport
and County Mayo